In 1790, Comte Mede de Sivrac...
...invented the world's first ever non-animal-powered vehicle.
It was called the "Celerifere."
By the mid-1800s,...
...the bicycle had gained steering capabilities, rubber tires and pedals.
The next step was to eliminate the manpower.
And in 1869, French bicycle manufacturer Pierre Michaux added pressurized steam,...
...getting the rider up to ten miles per hour.
The Industrial World were shifting from steam to combustion.
And so, the race to power up the motorcycle had taken off.
Almost a century after its bicycle ancestor,...
...the motorcycle was powered up with a v-twin engine from Gottlieb Daimler,...
...who later went on to join forces with Karl Benz to start Mercedes-Benz.